[Music]
oh that's the good stuff
and if i'm right if all of our hard work
has paid off
if all of the computer machines and the
electronic wires and all of the weirdo
gadgets that these two fine gentlemen
who are in this room with me right now
have been fiddling with all day if all
of that has come together if that red
light that i'm staring into is working
then this is officially
the first
reuben report
from my new house in florida there is an
awful
lot to talk about this is a rare
nighttime show for us but we got the
keys at about noon today it was a mad
dash to get in here it has taken about
two and a half almost three weeks extra
to actually get in here i thought we
were going to get to florida well i know
when we got to florida which was
december 18th i thought maybe we could
close on the house right before
christmas then i thought it would be
right after christmas then it looked
like it was going to be right after new
year that some other stuff happened then
all hell broke lose a whole bunch of
things related to covet and delays and
banks and loans and
all these different people pushing paper
across desks
but we made it we are in we've been
busting our butts all day long and this
is my first show from our temporary
florida home studio so i want to be very
clear as you're looking at the beautiful
florida sunset behind you uh sadly i do
not live right on the beach right on the
water just like that but we thought we'd
uh give you a nice feel of what it's
like to live in florida in the uh in
this beautiful time of year this is the
winter i almost said the summer but it's
the winter i guess people in florida are
saying
long time floridians are saying it's
been a little cold last week i think
it's been absolutely perfect every day
here for the last month has been
absolutely perfect like it's just been
absolutely wonderful by the way i am
drinking
dave's famous paloma
it's a tequila paloma sometimes people
do a gin paloma i like the tequila
paloma i normally wouldn't have my guys
drink during work
but i have allowed one paloma each to
con connor and michael
and we're very excited to be here uh
it's it's just been a crazy
crazy month so you all know i left
california i left california about a
month ago and we fled i mean we really
did flee i sold my house so quickly like
it was just like i didn't negotiate i
probably could have got more money i was
just like i have to leave this place is
collapsing they're going to come arrest
me the mob is going to show up at my
house i was like we just got to get out
we got to get out i don't care how we're
getting out we got to get out and then
we weren't sure when we were going to
close on the house here there were a
couple moving pieces things are a little
bit slower in general in florida the
real estate situation's a little bit
different also the real estate market
here is so ridiculously bananas hot that
you have to just get in on every house
that you like immediately and then
you're bidding against a million people
and i had to call in favors it was just
a situation
but we did get here we fled california
we got to the free state of florida and
since i've been here for the month i i
got to tell you i have seen more
happy people i've seen smiley people i
have seen fit people you know miami is
the most fit city in the united states
that's what they say just everyone looks
like a million bucks i have been to
packed restaurants i ate out at a
restaurant the other night this is a
place where you go where you sit down
usually with people that you know and
then perfect strangers bring you food in
exchange for money i haven't done that
in california in about two years so
everything's just been great here
there's such energy in this city i've
bounced around a little bit
throughout the florida area but mostly
i'm in the miami
sort of the rough miami area obviously i
can tell you exactly where i am but
rough miami area at the moment and it's
just great the refugees that are coming
here i know so many people moving here
right now even even in the month that
i've moved here i've inspired a couple
other people that i know and at least
two fans to move to florida like there's
just such great stuff happening here
like two days after we got here uh i was
at a party and the mayor was there mayor
suarez who came up to me and he's like
dave man i'm so happy you're here he
gives me a big fist bump and a hug and i
was like i was legit an enemy of the
state
like a month ago right like gavin newsom
had me on a list
and now i'm here where the is welcoming
me to the city as you guys know i was
invited to the governor's mansion with a
couple other people and i had a great
intimate dinner with ron desantis
governor ron desantis he was just great
like it was so cool going up to the
governor's mansion and
i had a little tequila at the end of the
night he i i don't think he was drinking
actually most of the other conservatives
they love their whiskey and their scotch
but he did have a cigar he did have a
cigar i think i can say that and uh and
just like to go there and like be
welcomed he was like dave we're so happy
you're here it's great like we love that
you brought your businesses here and
your family i'm like it's just
absolutely spectacular so my whole team
has has moved down here or is at least
in some version of the process of moving
down here at the moment everyone's
getting apartments buying stuff we're
helping the economy it's all good the
weather's been great the people
are happy
it's good guys can you think the
audience can tell that i'm happy can
they tell that everything's yeah i got
the thumbs up from both of you guys okay
yeah everything really has uh has just
been great here i'm super excited uh
first that we finally got the house of
course so referring to this little fun
background that we got behind us that's
our evening background right now so
while we're in the temporary studio in
the house because we are going to build
out a major studio while we're in the
temporary studio we've just got a screen
behind us and we're going to work on
some fun little things that we can do
with the screen this will be our evening
motif we're gonna have a morning motif
an afternoon motif maybe motifs will
change without me even knowing because i
can't see what's behind me so who knows
what connie's doing over there with the
computer i don't know
um
but yes we are going to build out the
main studio which will be a you know a
full proper set and all of that stuff
but obviously it's going to take a
little bit of time and i don't know if
you've heard
about this old fella there's this guy
very confused man by the name of joe
biden and he's the president or the man
pretending to be president and because
of him and his poor policies
there's been a lot of supply chain
issues so it is very hard to order
things right now it was not easy to get
all of these lights and the tv and the
tv stand and the thing that i'm putting
my paloma down on every now and again
and the desks i've been to ikea many
times how many times do we go to ikea in
the last two weeks 17 27 times a lot of
times so i can't even ikea we went to
ikea and even ikea is out of a lot of
stuff and there is nothing worse
than when you write down the number or
you take a picture of the ikea thing i'm
getting the lack shelf it's 129.5
it's in aisle 15 bin four and you're all
excited and you're going i'm going to do
ikea and it's great and i'm going to put
all the stuff together in the allen
wrench and the other thing and then you
go down
to the warehouse area and it's nothing
it's nothing there
it's it's a it's a zombie zone wasn't
that terrible here but it was we there
was a lot of stuff we couldn't get and
anyway so we've been trying to order
stuff for the studio a new not only a
new backdrop shelves
items all sorts of stuff
but things are just taking a lot of time
my house is completely empty right now
because well we've got basically a couch
and a carpet but other than that like
pretty much empty because the truck
that has all of our stuff we've got a
map you know big ass truck i think
that's the technical term the big ass
truck like the optimus prime truck
was in la and because we got delayed a
bit a little bit usually takes them like
four or five days to drive cross-country
if they're just like it's all your stuff
and we're just going right to you
uh but then we got delayed a couple days
so i had it in a warehouse in l.a and
then i told the guy okay you can leave
now because we're gonna be in the house
and everything and basically there is a
massive problem
in the trucking industry in the shipping
industry you guys know about this and i
think we've talked about a bit on the
show that basically because everybody is
moving from california
and new york the new york people go
straight down to florida the california
people go all the way across to florida
or some of them go to texas some of them
go to tennessee but basically everyone's
going that way or everyone's going
straight down nobody's going back up and
nobody's going west so the truck drivers
and the entire shipping industry this is
an industry built on oh we take stuff
this way we make money oh and then we
pick up stuff we go this way we take
money we go this way we make money we go
this way
and it ain't happening so there's been
all sorts of delays so we're not going
to have much stuff basically for the
next 12 or 14 days that'll be all right
we'll be okay we got a couple uh towels
at target and uh we got these fancy new
glasses that i'm drinking dave's
favorite paloma out of and uh you know
it's all gonna be okay um
i do want to just quickly uh thank a
couple people uh because you know this
was like just like a crazy thing like i
you know some people in life i think you
just make decisions and then you like
figure out all the other stuff after and
that's very much how i operate david
fills in all the little details and
that's why we're a great team together
um but when i made the decision to leave
california and obviously it had been
sort of a year coming and you all know
the story of you know roughly a year and
a half ago or even a little bit more at
the beginning of lockdown i'm sitting in
my backyard with michael knowles from
the daily wire and his wife and david
and we're sitting there and we're
drinking and we're having a good time
and it's a late night and we're all
going you know we're going to stay and
fight and we're going to defeat gavin
newsom this was before the recall even
but like we're going to save california
and then literally the next morning
daily wire announced they were moving to
nashville and knowles was gone but i did
decide to stay and fight obviously as
you know i think it's worth fighting
sometimes i really do i think you have
to stand your ground i think i do
believe that good ideas win uh over time
uh especially if you're you're brave
enough to put those ideas out there and
fight for what you believe in but you
can't win all the time and sometimes
things aren't worth saving and sometimes
if you try to save
somebody or something that wants to drag
you down with it well then that's what's
going to happen and i gave california an
extra year of my life and i'm not going
to sit here and tell you that my life
was terrible because it wasn't i have a
great life like truly blessed life and
i'm around great people and i'm in a
great relationship and i you know make
money and i have great businesses and
all of those things
but the place was crumbling the place
was crumbling the homelessness and the
drug use you guys know all this and just
everything felt wrong and the people
that wanted more lockdowns and more
masks and then there was the recall
election and it was a disaster and the
way the machine the entire
cultural and political machine
went after a great man larry elder a
great friend of mine and a great human
being more importantly the way they
called him the the black face of white
supremacy and i went and i traveled and
i toured with the guy and we were on
stage and it was amazing crowds and
the recall was just a disaster so i
don't know what to make of that other
than these people just want more they
want more and more rules around them
they want to be told what to do they
want to be spanked and and put into bed
in real tight
sheets and blankets and just
can't move and then you can wake me up
when you want because i need you to tell
me when i can get up and when i can go
to bed and everything else so the last
year you know even though what happened
in our house and we had great parties i
had a great 45th birthday party
i had we had great dinners all of these
things it was like i was never leaving
my house and when i was leaving my house
the few times that i did
i'd walk the dog and i'd sometimes get
sneered at for for not wearing a mask
while i'm outside in 85 degree weather
in california not walking the dog or
walking the dog but i'm not wearing a
mask right so i'd get sneered out for
that and just you know i'd go to
supermarkets and i didn't want to wear a
mask so i'd get yelled back by a
security guard and then i'd be inside
and some karen would yell at me and then
some other guy would yell at me and then
david who's completely tolerant of my
radical right-wing beliefs like we were
in the supermarket one time like right
around when i was like about to announce
that i wanted to leave about to really
tell him like we've got to go we have to
escape before they build the wall so
that we can't get out
we were in uh pavilion supermarket and i
wasn't wearing the mask and i had it in
my pocket you know so if someone wanted
to yell at me i could put it there and
that would stop kovid you know i think
that's how it works
um but someone was yelling at me and
david just turned to it he's like and
sort of with a smile on his face like it
wasn't in a dick way at all he was like
you know you don't have to come shopping
with me anymore and then i was like okay
we gotta go like this is so insane and
the level you all know these stories you
all have these stories in your life with
your family and everything else just the
level of insanity it's just like no more
i just didn't want anything to do with
it and then on top of everything else
and then i don't want to talk about
california ever again
maybe that's going to be the goal maybe
maybe every time i bring up california
on the show i'm not kidding i have to
pay money to something i'm really not
kidding like every time i reference
california if it just pops into my brain
i'm going to donate five dollars to
something the california like [ __ ]
association or something or
damn paloma you know what i mean you
know what i mean the california or the
refugee network we're going to figure
that out
something something larry elder's pack
yeah maybe that'll be it or how about
the save larry elder fund where i will i
will put up enough money the amount of
times that i say california show i'll
put up enough money to privately charter
a plane to get larry elder from the
dystopian nightmare of california to the
free
state of florida i'm not kidding we
should do something like that let's
let's make note of that every time i
bring it up you know just sort of
gratuitously i will put five bucks
towards towards something uh but then of
course after the that starts after
today's show by the way because i just
got to finish up what i'm saying here
but uh
we uh we get through the recall and then
three days after the recall i got
audited by the state
audited by the state and it's like we
know this is what they do lois lerner
remember that whole scam irs
scam during the obama years like they
use the the levers of government as
weapons and it's like maybe it's a
coincidence that i got audited after the
state after trying to take out gavin
newsom but maybe not and i was just like
okay that's it and i have to say
and then we'll move on to florida i have
to say that when i brought it to my team
i brought it to david
talked to helen my my whole team and it
was like everybody was like yeah let's
go like it was almost like they were all
waiting for me to say it like dave what
are we all doing here like
it's time to go man and uh fair to say
you're happy here
fair to say you're happy here
everybody's happy everybody's happy
everyone looks like a million bucks i
think we've all lost a little weight
it's just like everybody's happy the
food the scene the restaurants
everything
is amazing so i'm just incredibly
appreciative of not only my team who
showed up and has busted their butts to
uh to build out the studio to get us
back in line
but but the people there are a couple
people i don't even want to mention
names because i know they don't want
verbal shout outs but somebody who
helped me tremendously yesterday in the
midst of like some last minute crazy
work craziness involving paperwork you
know who you are and you're watching i
hope and thank you thank you thank you
and then to the couple who i i hope is
watching as well uh who hooked us up at
their house for the last month so that
we didn't have to bounce around hotels
and uh you just took extraordinary care
of us and clyde and it ain't easy to
have a dog in hotels and you just let us
stay every time i called you and i was
like i got another sob story they moved
the date again and i got to stay one
more day
and it was like you're welcome you're
welcome to stay and you put all that
cereal in the in the closet in the
kitchen and it's amazing i ate a lot of
cereal this they have a lot of cereal in
the kitchen in the closet and i ate i
probably three boxes of frosted mini
wheats that's not healthy but i did it
nonetheless okay it was it was a
stressful month or something i got
covered nobody cares about that i got
covered it was a pleasure i had that for
a couple days my knees hurt that was
like the really my legs ached for a
couple days it did hit david a little
bit harder we're here in florida we got
monoclonal treatment real quick i took a
little ivermectin it didn't turn me into
a horse i've had this penchant for sugar
cubes lately but that's about it like it
was just fine michael got covered cotter
did not get covered so you should be
studied you should be like taken to a
science place where the science people
are and they should study you because
everyone you know got covered except for
you very bizarre
but it's just it's just been great here
so anyway the purpose of tonight really
more than anything else is i just wanted
to say hello to you guys i really
realized
in this last month you know we did uh
five shows last week at newsmax oh so i
do want to thank the folks at newsmax uh
particularly my buddy john bachman who
hooked up the situation and the staff
there was great and they let us do our
thing and it was just wonderful being
there i loved being in boca it was just
fun and like just nice to be in another
city and see some other people a lot of
old jews there so i basically pretended
that i was in an episode of seinfeld del
boca vista the whole time it was really
great saw morty and you know the whole
hell in the whole thing
and uh
we did that and then really the purpose
of this tonight was that we i just
wanted to do a real thank you to you
guys and i realized i really realized
and i know this may sound cliche or
silly or pandering or something but it
really is true
like how much i love my job i was
like not happy as happy as i've been
here the only thing that i wasn't happy
about was that i couldn't do this i
couldn't talk to you guys directly i did
a bunch of local stuff and i was live
streaming and and all that and
communicating with people on there and
that locals is now the only place that i
respond to anybody and i talk to people
and it's great we're building an amazing
community but i miss doing the work here
of the show right like i missed like
talking to you guys about the news you
know i'd see things that twitter is not
the same it's just not the same it's old
negative [ __ ] but not even that all
the interactions are just purely
meaningless
like i missed like talking to you guys
about the news communicating things the
the biden press conference that we
covered last week like there were so
many instances of that the viral videos
and getting in here and and talking
about the news and sometimes being silly
and sometimes being serious and doing
something that is value you know i can't
tell you the amount of people that have
come up to me here you know i always
tell you it's like when people come up
to me they're always nice but something
about being here the people that have
come up to me
like they're like overjoyed they're like
thrilled that i'm here they they
just are welcoming when i was waiting
for my uh for my buddies the other night
at stk in miami beach would you ever
want to go to a steak joint that is loud
like a club and they got that
thump-a-thumpa thumpa and you can't hear
anybody
that's the place to go but the food was
great atmosphere was great all good loud
fun whatever i'm sitting at the bar
waiting for my friends and this couple i
don't know probably like mid-60s sitting
next to me
and the woman's looking at me she keeps
looking at me and then the guy goes
you're not gonna i don't know if you
know who this is you look like this dave
rubin guy you ever hear this dave rubin
guy you look like dave rubin i was like
i have heard of dave rubin
he's right here and i was like i've just
had so many great experiences of just
people being happy and nice i'm not
kidding even like stuff here at the
house like
the the inspectors are nicer and that is
what i want to devote my life to i am
not kidding i am here now in the free
state of florida to keep florida florida
there is something right here something
really really right and by the way it's
not just here it's not just here of
course it's in texas of course it's in
tennessee of course it's there are
pockets of it even in blue states
believe it or not and of course there
are other red states and everything else
and not that the solutions are all
political
but people have managed somehow in
certain places to figure out a way to
live a free life of their own accord and
doesn't mean they're perfect i certainly
ain't perfect but like people are
figuring it out people are figuring out
how to tune out the lunacy how to focus
on the things that give them value and
joy and passion and all of those things
and i want the message of what has gone
right here in florida i want that to
resonate throughout the country that is
now the driving force of what i do in
many ways fortunately it's what my new
book is out which comes out in april
don't burn this country
and it's all good you know people are
live chatting in locals right now so if
you want to go to
reubenreport.locals.com oh man
michael almost took out the whole system
right there almost knocked over the
paloma right onto all the fancy new
equipment
it all could end it well that's what a
test stream is all about can
the supercomputer survive tequila and
grapefruit juice
these are the things we're testing out
right now but people right now are
chatting in
rubinreport.locals.com so you can throw
me a couple of them craig this is this
is important we don't have our
teleprompter set up yet by the way
that's why i'm looking a little bit this
way because he's showing me on a
traditional computer these are all the
inner workings of a youtube show that
you might not know normally
this is an important question craig
how's the humidity treating your hair
i got to say i'm feeling pretty good
about the hair game i still don't have a
stylist if you're watching this right
now and you are a great miami hair
stylist i need somebody i'm about five
weeks out from a haircut my girl jess
jess i love you i miss you can i fly you
out here
if not i need somebody in miami like
obviously i need somebody so if you're a
hair stylist mommy reach out to me the
best way to get me is at locals but find
a way to get to me but i need everything
i need a dentist i need a dermatologist
uh you know i wouldn't mind getting a
massage every now and again if you're a
masseuse what else do people need i need
a uh
what optometrist my eyes are fine thank
you but i guess if i had some strainage
of the eyes uh i could need an
optometrist uh ali says you need to post
the paloma recipe ali i appreciate that
and uh first off uh you know david puts
a lot of his recipes at
davidscookbook.com he's an incredible
chef or you can check him out on
instagram at david's cookbook and he is
actually working on a real cookbook like
a legit cookbook which i'm super psyched
about because i want to share some of
these great meals and a lot of you in
the community have made a bunch of his
stuff i think the cast iron chicken parm
usually is number one and the uh the
non-fried chicken wings also do quite
well but there will be some drinks in
there and then the book is gonna take an
interesting other turn so it's not just
a cookbook but i can't get into that but
i'm gonna have a little something to do
with that i think um but the paloma
recipe well i'll be quite honest
this paloma is very simple because as
you can see you're not getting much of a
pink there in a normal paloma you'd be
getting your grapefruit juice you'd be
getting a pinker thing i didn't have a
grapefruit here we're running low on
supplies i had to do what i could
grab the grab the tequila well i filled
it up with ice there we go
filled up my new fancy glass from target
at ice with ice
went with the tequila didn't measure
just did what i had to do and then it's
just a grapefruit spin drift you guys
know about the spin drift i'm like
addicted to this stuff it's basically
club soda with just like a splash of
different juices so this one's
grapefruit but they got raspberry they
got lime lemon you know they got they
got an arnold palmer they got all sorts
of stuff um normally i would put some
lime juice in there but really for a
good paloma to me it's just like club
soda grapefruit juice
lime ice like you're good to go you
could put like a little fruit in there
if you want
but this is this is pretty pretty pretty
basic let's see rob says i'm pretty sure
that i'm on newsome's list as well yeah
the guys definitely got a list like
that's what they love these people love
lists does that count as me talking
about california he duped me and i said
it's after today anyway so uh richard
says let's go brandon ain't it the truth
man and by the way uh michael is here in
a let's go brandon shirt very exciting
very exciting how's the stream going
guys has anything crashed we feel good
about this it's all it's all good um
so
all right we're gonna we're gonna rap
because my guys have been busting their
butts all day we wanted to do about a
half hour
make sure the computers weren't gonna
crash and that everything else was gonna
be okay so yeah i think we're gonna be
in this studio or some form of it
it's a little hard to say honestly
because of the supply chain stuff like
we're ordering backdrops
and bookshelves and all the trinkets and
lights and you know we're gonna hang
like we got a lot of stuff to do we'll
be here but the show will be as sharp as
always our teleprompter does arrive in a
day or two uh so then i can get messages
directly so i don't have to look that
way because i would imagine in the last
half hour when you saw me look away
you're going what's he doing what's over
there as opposed to looking directly at
you uh so we'll have the teleprompter
and uh and you know we have some we have
some tricks and and fun stuff coming
over the next little bit uh but i'm
really psyched to be back and i just
want to thank you guys all for your
patience
um oh and very importantly um you do
have to note that we are changing the
time of the show
uh we started it last week but
officially
really officially starting tomorrow
because i'm really considering this sort
of the new beginning is today today is
sort of day one of the whole operation
our new live stream time every day
monday tuesday wednesday thursday and
friday at 11 a.m eastern
we used to be at 2 p.m eastern which was
11 a.m pacific we are now at 11 a.m
eastern
and uh
i think that's it i think that's it i
just really i want to thank you guys
um you've helped me build something here
that that is awesome and growing oh i
officially want to welcome phoenix uh to
the team phoenix was our intern and can
i say well that he didn't he left uh can
i say the thing yeah he left college to
get a job here he was like you know what
why am i wasting my time on these zoom
meetings with the masks and the morons
and i was like you want a job you got a
job man i'm paying you and i think he
moves in like in two days from now
so i'm just super psyched that you guys
are part of this adventure i promise you
that if you think that anything that
i've done over the last few years has
been halfway decent that we are going to
make it all better and i'm truly feeling
inspired sometimes you have to look for
inspiration in life right like you don't
feel it you're you're out of touch with
what's going on you're a little lost
whatever like no
not for me at the moment we're going to
save florida we're going to save
america and then we're going to save the
world i got nothing better to do than
save the world do you
let's find out
adios